hello everyone this is grandmaster
varacobian and we're going to be
doing a lecture today lecture is a
little bit earlier today
and it's going to be a master's choice
so we'll have two lectures back to back
so don't go anywhere for the next hour
and 45 minutes okay so
i'll be giving you lectures and puzzles
in this game
i want to in this lecture i want to show
you my game against
uh grand master milixep kachiyan
this is played in a national open
tournament
in las vegas okay so i played d4
my opponent played knight f6 c4
g6 knight city grunfeld
he is known he is known to be a
groomfield player
so this came as a no surprise you know i
was expecting
i was anticipating that he might play
the groomfield
so i played here bishop g5
i like this idea now i'm trying to put
pressure on f6
if opponent captures if y can get e4 in
and then take the pawn on c4 with a very
pleasant advantage okay
so now he goes knight e4 activating the
knight
and attacking my bishop so i dropped the
bishop back here
knight takes c3 c3 bishop g7
so basically here a block has few
options you can take on c4 or you can
play bishop g7
these are the two options okay c4
e3 c5
the idea is to try to attack my center
okay
so i cook here
i'm doubling the double palms
knight f3
knight c6
and now i play queen b3 the point here
is i'm trying to exchange the queens
if i can exchange queens
you know if it takes i can take my with
the a pawn then i have pressure
along the a file okay so that's exactly
what i'm trying to do here
uh my opponent goes to queen takes b3 i
was happy to see this because after this
take
now i can take back and now i have a
rook
that is basically in the game as well
here
and now my opponent takes none of my
opponent takes
and here is the first test and i want
you to try to make a decision here
how should i try to respond here how
should i try to recapture here okay
now i want to ask you a question here
what do you think what do you think here
you should try to do here
because you can you want to capture back
but but how
how you want to capture back i'm going
to get my ipad to see the chat okay guys
so think about it
how to capture here
okay
okay
now let's see here you have a choice
here guys you have a choice
so how to how to uh
respond in this position okay how to
respond here
as far as capturing it here
you can take with a c pawn you can take
with the
uh you can take with a c pawn you can
also take with the e pawn
so you have few options here that you
can try to do it
um i kind of wanted to keep my uh i
wanted to keep my
uh structure together so i decided to
take this way because if i take this way
now i have a weak b3 pawn i have an
isolated pawn
okay so he goes here now he plays e5
a very aggressive move and now he's
trying to put pressure
this is a very aggressive move and idea
is to put pressure
and try to break the center okay
all right guys i could see the chat now
so
if you have any questions you can put it
okay so now
there is a break there is a break here
and if i take now he's just gonna take
back with a knight
i don't see any advantage after this
okay
so if you take he's just going to take
back so you have to do something better
here
you have to do something better here
guys what can you do
you know as this is you have to make a
decision here
so what would be the right decision here
you know we can try to go bishop b5 as
an alternative for example
so there are there are some options
yeah i i decided that i should play uh
i decided i should take uh play d5 here
to attack the knight okay
now he goes e4 attacking
my knight
so d5 e5 and now suddenly c3 pawn is
hanging
okay
now my knight is hanging and also he is
threatening to play bishop takes c3
so it looks like i might be in some
trouble here
hey jeffy now
all right guys i have the i can see the
chat now so let's see here
hello hello everybody welcome welcome
everybody and i'm glad you're here
from all over the world we have students
so let's see here so what do you think i
should do here my knight is under attack
he's threatening also bishop c3 so the
question is
what should i do here
so what are the options here
well if i go k2 he's just gonna take
this
this and just take he's just happy
well if i play a long castle then again
i think it's
not clear i actually played here 92
because now i'm threatening to take on
e4 and he played here because if he
plays here
i actually have the movie rook c1
hitting the bishop if bishop b2 i go
rook c2 now i'm winning a piece because
the knight and the bishop are hanging if
he goes anywhere i take the knight so
now he can take
but this position is very serious for
him too because
my dark squares are very strong i have
bishop f6 idea
rook c7 i have bishop b5 i have lots of
active pieces
okay now he goes 97
you know i can i can try to play with
bishop f6
and then rook a1 camina white white is
slightly better
now he played knight to
b4 because if i take now he's going to
take my rook
so if i take he's going to play bishop
to a1
if i take he's just gonna play bishop to
a1
and the threat is bishop c3 threat is
knight d5
uh threat is knight c2
uh if you played this then
i mean even this could be a problem then
you're gonna take on c3
hitting your rook that's just the first
idea there might be some other
issues here as well yeah
knight takes c4 correct now you're
protecting
c3 and now he canceled because if he
goes here
i actually take him d2
if you take
okay
well i take and now this is actually a
very very serious compensation because
my pieces are very very active here
my bishops my knight the pawn on d5 so
this is uh
probably going to be a nice advantage
here for white despite
you know despite being down exchanging
you know
so now it goes bishop d7
knight d6 so that's why my opponent even
though he had this opportunity to play
knight c2 but
he he decided that it's going to be too
dangerous
now he goes castle
so
okay and now what do i do now after he
plays long castle what can i do guys
now what to do here what would be the
best option here for white
castles
bishop f5 see i castle because to have
the king saved and now he goes here
attacking my knight now he's attacking
my knight
ugh
yeah now bishop bishops are very strong
they're attacking and the knight only
four is attacking as well
so
the bishops are too strong you need to
try to shut down one of the bishops
yes absolutely correct dylan that's why
we
we play long castle so we can support
the d-file
bishop b7 i'm not sure
the idea is try to activate the knight
so i go knight f6
now when i'm shutting down this knight
bishop
if he takes i take back of the bishop so
he goes here
and if i take the knight then there's uh
rook c8 shack
and rook c2 ideas so that's why king b2
moving the king here and now stopping
all the checks or anything here
all right goes h6 idea behind this move
is guys
is to play g5 so if i take
simply play g5 attack the bishop bishop
goes back
bishop six check now king has to go
a2 i have
this one threatening
two ideas
so now he wants to play g5 here can we
do something guys can we do something to
prevent that
okay let me look at the shot here yes
the idea is
f4 absolutely that's the right way to
stop him from playing g5
correct now he goes knight c2 now he's
trying to go some knight e3 ideas
okay
now h3 the point of h3 is to try to play
g4
and attack the bishop okay d8
g4
simply attacking the lights for bishop
if what i can take if he takes on f6
that bishop h6 check so now he's
you know he's forced to do some things i
mean if he goes back to you know he goes
back to see
he loses this so basically the knight is
you know right he's trapped i think he
probably should have done this
and i attack and just play this position
but this is probably also
very bad because uh white is up a pawn
i'm up a pawn and plus the knight on f6
is super annoying g4 is still coming up
rook has yeah i mean i still have g4 i
still have a k7
putting pressure
take
yeah rook 88 g4
93
rookie one attacking the knight
bishop c4 now here we are in this
endgame
i'm up a pawn but my opponent has two
bishops
and
i have to play precisely to convert this
okay
so first things first here what to do
it's important when you get the winning
position you just
uh take a little break and just
take your time when you already have a
really good position okay
yeah you just get back you need to try
to understand what is it trying to do
you know my idea is to try to you know
improve my pieces and push
okay and try to promote those pawns
rook d1 first protecting my pawn
thank you guys thank you i'm glad you've
been watching the youtube videos now he
plays b5
because now he's gonna have some b4
ideas so i didn't want to allow that
so i fix him now now my king position is
very safe so he plays a5
positionally he's lost i'm just gonna go
here here
i mean if he plays uh
you know if he plays here
i can't even just go here attack
yeah bishop f6 winning
because here you can just
just f5 f6 uh
now i played a5 trying to complicate the
position of this move
i took now he plays before
take back now we have three puns now he
goes here trying to win a piece
but that simply can be prevented right
guys
that simply can it can be prevented here
that is how
now what can you do guys
we need to protect we need to protect
yes so here
now he takes he takes the pawn and now
we just bring the rook back
our pawns are very strong once they
start rolling okay
now he goes back here
and now what is the idea guys
finishing idea here what is it
uh which piece we should try to improve
here
bishop f2 because i want to put that
bishop to c5 okay
well he sacrificed because he was
already down the pawn and he couldn't
see
enough counter play that's why he did
that now he goes here
king a3 this way i'm avoiding all the
tactics
take take he cannot take because i have
bishop d4 pin
now ok seven attacking the bishop if
take i will take the bishop so bishop b5
bishop c5 i push
now attacking the bishop
and now d7 is coming up and now after d7
there's
too many threats one two
now play here trade he resigns because
if it takes
i take
now he takes now we simply play rook to
d8
giving check okay yeah
yeah he was he was actually now i take
and now this is
i just continue pushing accurately this
part
into a quit yeah this was a good good
game definitely
yeah this was definitely a good game
guys
um there was a good question it says why
did he sacrifice the two pawns
well if he doesn't sacrifice anything
how can he get any control play here
because i'm up a pawn
and i have a better position
yeah because if you go here i have this
attacking the coin
back i have f5
now threatening f6
you know now it's just straight right
into play f6 and blockade
bishop so that's that's why he tried to
look we'll go for a counter play
that's what he was trying to do he was
trying to look for a counter play guys
okay that's why i sacrificed
yeah now the knight is very strong and
the critical moment here a5 why did you
play a5 it's
a5 is probably not a very good move but
on the other hand
position is very difficult my plan is
very simple rookie one rookie seven
uh trade some more pieces
and
should be a comfortable win the knight
on f6 is is a very very annoying piece
it's a very strong piece
okay now take
and here yeah i just uh had to be
accurate
i had to have this move ready okay
now everything is lined up and
all right guys this is the first
position it's block to play
and win block to play and win guys
what can you do here think about it
block to play and win
now what to do guys
black to play and you need to find a
winning continuation
and you're down two pounds okay you are
down two pounds
oh wait bishop jiho now no bishop g for
now
yeah you have to really calculate this
okay
so what do we do here
okay yeah yeah that's fine that's fine
that's fine see you can you know you'll
get the next one okay
so what is the idea here what block can
really try to do here
you see a waist block and try to go for
a win here
so what is the idea here hello hello
manny hello manny mp how you doing hello
now what is the plan here we're trying
to get a queen on h3
of course we're trying to something like
this
but it's not easy to do it here it's not
easy to do it guys
now if you play here queen e6
it looks like it's just going to be
perfect you go here
and if it goes here you just take it
takes you just take the
here
and if he takes back with the queen
if he takes back with the queen what are
we gonna do
yep bishop c6
correct correct armin bishop c6 and now
you're attacking the queen
and rook and winning winning the
material okay
yeah so that's why but there is a
problem guys
when you play queen e6 white has an
excellent defense here
okay
yep now what is the idea he has though
and now the idea is what is white going
to do here this is just gonna
just resign is white gonna resign or
he's gonna try to come up
with some kind of resource
queen takes f8 correct
we takes their faith that's the point
now he takes
check
yeah now i just check
and at the end of this it's just going
to be two extra pounds
for white so white will be uh you know
dominating with good winning chances
here
so it's still you know you can't be
completely
relaxed here there are some threads for
white as well in this position okay
now what you can do first you have to do
something first
and then your queen e6 id is gonna work
so we just take
and it takes with the queen we have
bishop c6 attacking the queen and
picking up the pawn
and if he takes back with this now
now what you're gonna do
you do this because you want to
eliminate uh this queen f8
and when we give a check the bishop on
b5 guarding this ea squash
and now a quiet move yes
yeah just go here attacking the rook
and attacking the pawn all right
so yeah in this position you just uh
here
there's also this idea look
here here in a spectacular check
if he takes rook h6 mate
he doesn't want to take
yeah the mate
all right so that's the position here
guys and the winning move here is
rook takes b5 okay
all right let me set up some more
puzzles for you here guys
all right this one is also very
interesting it's wide
to play and win why
to play and win
well there's a two pawn advantage for
black two bishops
now what's the idea here
what what i can really try to do here to
organize a very very strong attack here
now i'm going to give you a couple of
minutes okay
um
now what's the idea here let's see here
yeah yeah this was a nice idea knight g5
threatening queen h7
if it takes you simply go queen g6 and
you have bishop e4
and threatening bishop h78 the question
is
when if he was here what do you do
yeah just the idea is to try to
complicate
complicate the matters
okay
now we have to see
first of all are we gonna take or how we
gonna do it
now we have to take we have to take care
and what's the best way to recapture so
we still have our threats
okay that's one idea
okay
now he takes
and it's the same idea just except the e
pawn is gone okay
yeah just go here
and you're gonna go bishop e4 next okay
and you go bishop before next
okay perfect guys so again when
opponent's piece is on develop you can
try to go for direct attack like this
okay all right i'm gonna set up one more
position for you
um
okay
okay
with no puns on the board this will be
uh
with no puns on the board guys this
should be a draw
if if if you cannot do anything right
away with no pawns on the board this
should be a draw
uh but again it's a very concrete
position okay
so think
so i need you to calculate the whole
concept here okay
when you go for this i want you to
calculate the whole concept okay
uh this is i think uh stockfish
right now i turn it off but it's a stock
fish
stock fish stock fish 11.
now what do we do here how are we gonna
do it guys
well you need to give me the whole line
so far i'm seeing only one move
you're just saying bishop g2 and it wins
but
i need to put the whole line here guys
bishop g2 uh
blocks okay what is the best defense
there are two best defenses here for
black
what are the best defenses here huh
what are the best defenses here
so now he can play if he goes here what
is the solution guys
if he goes here now what's the mate here
guys
show me the mating too
yes so we go here
make perfect if he goes here now what
are you gonna do
if he goes to f7 what's the difference
now
how can we try to go for a win
now we have to go rook h3 correct
i made
i may try this all right so black has
two more defenses here guys one is rook
f8 and one is rook f8 so he's going to
go here first
look at fade
now what do you do
if he goes to f8 what are we gonna do
now
yeah well no not look h3 now you need to
cut him off
now yeah bishop c3 is not a suicide he
has f1 check
now what is the idea here you have to
make the correct move to actually put
them into a success
yeah king here and now he's in trouble
because if he moves check
you go check and you take the rook okay
you can't do anything
all right and now so basically that puts
him in a success what if he goes this
direction
okay
all right he goes there now what are you
gonna do
rook g3 correct
now he goes here
yeah check he goes here now he wants to
go to k6 check
so now we're gonna play
which move we're gonna play to put him
into the suk
perfect now if he checks i'm just gonna
go to g1 check
okay here
i go here check and pick up the rook
okay
yeah again normally guys bishop and rook
versus rook is a theoretical draw
but in this particular position it's not
so simple because you know
uh it's losing because the king and a
rook are placed on the wrong squares
and that's why it's a problem okay so
you have to remember these positions
these are these are very very important
positions okay
okay guys we're going to take a short
break don't go anywhere and then we're
going to start the next class which is
called
the games of the week okay so next there
will be games of the week here
so give me about five minute break and
then i'll be back here stay tuned okay
stay tuned guys i'll be right back
okay all right guys i am back
and we're gonna start our second lecture
okay and in this lecture we're gonna do
some practical positions okay
i'll be setting up some practical
positions by grand masters
i'll be asking you to find the
continuations okay
all right so this is the first position
for you
alright guys
all right guys this is the practical
position this is a game of
uh practical position the game of um
uh carwana versus ivan chuck
okay caruana versus evancho guys so
yeah as long as you work hard you you
know you will be able to you know you
might be able to become a grandmaster
you just have to work hard okay
like you like remember that all right
guys
white to play wide
to play and you need to find the right
continuation here okay
so what do we do here
so what is the right way to continue
here guys
okay hello hello everybody hello
greetings
yeah so this position is a fabiano car
okay all right guys
white to play what to do
so why to play what are we gonna do here
guys
all right perfect perfect guys so i need
you to play like
fabiano caruana here i'm going to give
you a couple of minutes to think and i
want to see you
putting the moves in the chat here so we
can see the answer okay
again karana didn't play the most
effective way karana played bishop here
here bishop d7
and
he played here actually if opponent
takes he was hoping to do this
now b7 is hanging and
something like this and try to give mate
to his opponent you know
but unfortunately after rook t7
uh there's a queen c8 move
and here would have been some advantage
still for caruana but he played
knight f7
knight d7 knight h6
king h7 and
yeah and it ended in a draw here
queen h5 knight f6
if you move back you can just take so i
guess you have to play check
here check here
okay until
it's just a draw
it's not made but sorry there's no map
because i have this
okay but you have a draw
in this position and there's no time to
lift the rook because your rook is
misplaced here is placed here all right
so so h3 is not a move h3 allows
black to play bishop to b7 okay
what you think what do you think he
should do here
what do you think caruana should have
done here it's a surprising move but a
very strong one okay
because white has such a nice leading
development with those rooks you know
i mean this is this is this is very
strong this is very strong
and this is a vacancy tournament 2012
2012 vacancy tournament
[Music]
so so far i'm not seeing the moves guys
so far
i'm not seeing the move yet it's
something very concrete
very uh a drastic idea okay
so this is something very concrete very
drastic you have to play
yeah no something fast something fast
you have to play here okay
yeah no i still don't see it yet this
this is definitely a surprising idea
i'm not surprised that caruana didn't
play this movie because
it doesn't look like he's going to be
doing that much
we have to start an attack right away
okay
what's the best way to start the attack
here guys
what is the best way to start the attack
what will be the best way to start the
attack
yes g4 correct
it's a very surprising mode very good
one now he goes here bishop here
when you say a you say b right which one
i was here 95.
now i play g5
white is just winning takes pawn takes
actually
and then queen h5 so he goes here
group sorry rook 88
now what to do rook 88
now we need to open up the position take
check
and here now threatening to take on h6
and black cannot defend h6 spawn
there are more moves needs to be played
but the whole point is you don't have a
good way to defend against h6
and if you go here if you go here
this bishop can join in action as well
also this is a good move to take on h6
and if he goes here
um
oh
and now here bring this guy
now he goes here
you check
and now you have this check winning the
quinn
okay but i mean to find a move g4 is
it's it's not an easy move to find but
again if the pawn is on h6
this is a target so you want to play g4
h4
and g5 to attack okay because h6
is a target so you can use this
moment to attack okay attack
the weakest square okay we're gonna do
one more guys
okay
all right guys it's a
white to play and you need to figure out
the way
to win this game and this is a game
sergey karjakin
playing white against grand master
alexey alexey so you have to figure out
a way
to break through here okay
so let's let's think about this a little
bit
white to play and win
calculate calculate guys you have to
calculate you can't just
throw a bishop h7 out there and expect
it's gonna work
you have to show precise calculation
okay you have to show precise
calculation here
so the first move is very important you
know because your knight is under attack
and that could that could be an issue
the knight is under attack at the moment
but what can be done
all right i see some ideas okay you guys
have some ideas so the
the first move is actually h6 that's
correct
the the reason is if he takes
which is going to be first check
check check
and make okay
so we're going to be first to give the
mate okay
so now after h6 though he's got a couple
of options he can play g6
or queen e5 if he plays g6
first of all if you play g6 now what are
you gonna what are you gonna do
now it's a very very special move
because he wants to play
queen takes pawn okay
he wants to play queen takes pawn
and now we have to we have to play this
correctly okay
if we play bishop c4 the problem is he's
going to go bishop c4
and then his queen e5 thread is still
remaining
to eliminate uh to eliminate my pawn and
defend against queen f6 like this here's
this
defending against the trap
so we want to do something that will be
able to
attack
94 and it takes
so you have to figure out the way that
you can mate him here
it's a double exclamation mark here that
you're going to do okay
it's a double exclamation mark here guys
a very very nice tactic okay
yes adeel mcdonald yes a deal
knight d5 the point is if he takes to
the bishop
you go queen f6 and queen g7 mate he no
longer has queen e5
okay that's one and the second idea if
he takes back with the queen
then what can we do here what can we
insert here guys
what can we insert so we have the mating
idea
if he takes back with the queen what can
we do
it takes if it takes
just here it's mate
and it takes back the queen
and he's trying to take another pawn on
a2 so i would just play b3
then he has to go back and then play f6
yeah you have to play b3 because he goes
back and now to queen f6
i mean and then
the only way to stop the threat is going
to be to play queen takes e5 okay
and yes queen takes e5 that's right
so yes he has this idea but okay this is
just lost
all right okay guys so that's one so
h6 g6 we are winning because of this
fantastic move
okay but what about this
h6 g6 what about this idea of
now what to do here
now what can we do
yeah so we start with this check
he takes back
now what what are we doing here
seven check king h7
take
now you go here
threatening queen h6 check create
68 now the idea is
now black has to go here guys
and the block goes here what is the
correct move
queen
[Music]
no
there are many moves guys there are many
many moves but what is the best move
what is the most precise move here
you're going to do
yeah there are many many options here
but which one would be the best
queen f6 i like that yes enough six
threatening mate
made shade so he has to do something and
take
take back attacking the rook rook has to
move
and now the rook moves made in two
the rook moves we have a maiden two okay
check animate
animate that's tiny okay
all right very good guys excellent
so that's the complete solution for this
one
so again it's a very tricky moment
because you're under attack as well
and it's very
it's very tempting to do something
like 94 but if you do 94 then
different game okay guys i'm gonna set
up the next position for you
and i gotta get my charger
okay
okay so this is the
this is the black pieces
and block is to play and win
bishop c1
okay we should see one
actually it's a coin
all right guys it's uh it's kramnik
it's white and his opponent is ivan
chuck
okay
ivan chuck is black kramnik is white
black to play and proceed okay
block to play and proceed
so what is the first move here for black
now there is a nice leading development
here is the question is
could this lead that be transposed
to something more something more
significant okay
so think for a couple of minutes guys
think for a couple of minutes
and then you can say your answer
get my charger
now what do we do here guys how do we
try to win this position
um
it's black to move
it's back to move right
kramnik had taken too many chances and
now ivan chuck
is gonna try to take advantage of it
okay
too many chances now what to do
uh
[Music]
if you go here guys what is this
i'm going to take queen b7 if you go
here
yeah i mean
yeah i mean
you know i mean there's a lot of pawns
here you know there's three pawns for a
piece here
so it's not so simple here this position
okay not so simple
so that's why we don't want to play
rookie eight okay
so what did iwan chook what did evan
shook play here
what did ewan should do in this position
yeah so what kramnik uh what what do you
want shook try to do
what you want to try to do in this
position guys is the idea is
to try to start the attack okay
so he didn't want to play something like
g6 so he immediately went for
f4
trying to open up the position it takes
takes and open up and enter
with tactics so
it's going to place g3 g4
and now what to do now with this knight
this knight is trapped
okay so he clearly had an idea
when he played this move he didn't just
play this out of nowhere right
now what is the move here can you play
like ivan chook yes
knight g3 correct
now if you take here she's gonna take
attack is very very strong
okay attack is very strong
now he plays b4
the point is to try to deflect
try to deflect the bishop
now what are we gonna do after b4
no no no no not bishop too you need to
concentrate on trying to chop this queen
and now you go back here
yeah now after rook 8 he goes 95
92 check with bishop takes
let's take back like this
92 check king f1
should take 96
and now black uh
black is just winning here but play the
bad move knight c3 knight c3 is a
mistake
the winning move here is knight d4
because here we take here
yeah virtually you know also you take
back the pawn on g4 so eventually this
will be
sorted out for advantage for black okay
so if we go back to the original
position
so basically you have this position
where it's
it's hard because uh white is also very
solid
so your attack is very very southern
okay
hello boris trosman hello hello is the
raspberry buddies
and now f4 sacrificing material
to go for the win all right very good
guys and now we're gonna do the last one
okay the last position for today
okay and i'll be back again next
thursday
so make sure you check out also the
sunday classes as well but definitely
next thursday we'll have
another class like this okay
all right
all right let's see here
go i'll remove the queen
white to play and win
all right this is white to play
and win
all right why to play and win this is a
game of
aberbach okay against aronin
in 1963 in moscow
so let's see if you can find it okay
think guys what to do here
how to proceed here
how to attack how to proceed
in this position here guys
think for a second okay think for a
second to see if you can find
the correct continuation here the
position is still protected
position is you know pieces are
protecting each other
so you have to do something okay
all right take your time guys and find
the solution here okay
find the correct solution here guys
you have to figure out what is the
defense which piece is the defense and
how are you going to try to
get rid of that defense
you really want to sacrifice only six
but you can't right now successfully
because
it's protected
okay
all right so we needed deflection
unfortunately c4
it's not a deflection because c4 she
will play
this and then it's pinning okay
so unfortunately c4 is not a good
deflection
okay
we need to make sure that bishop moves
now i'm seeing it bishop c6 is correct
yes
now he has to take because otherwise we
take bishop takes d5
okay so he has to take
now position has been weakened
yeah if he doesn't take we just take on
d5 and rookie seven
so for example yeah so this
let's say it tries to go here
we just take take rookie seven so he has
to pick
once he takes now we can take only six
but with what
what are we gonna take with only six
rook no i don't think you want to take
the look
at this guy knight takes
check can't go up can't go anywhere so
it has to go here
and now we got to take on d6 we gotta
take on d6 but how
how are we gonna take guys with which
piece
with which piece we're going to take on
d6 now
rick dd6 yes now you're threatening
queen f8
and i mean there's so many threats you
have so he can't do anything okay
but to sacrifice back take
take king c7
but the problem now we have too many
puns okay
the problem now we have too many puns
now so
after king c7 he went
yeah because really he cannot defend now
queen f8 rook c6
so he goes now we go to t2
rook a8
b3 check
now took another pawn
check
now he goes here because if he take with
the bishop he takes the rook
check with the rook takes the bishop
king is actually well placed here and
the same idea pushed a pawn
and now
nice nice tactic here nice tactic you
guys have here to win some material
now it's a tactical idea here
yes a6 correct now if he takes with the
kink
you just take on c7 if he takes with
this you have this trick
okay a6 now he played here
and now we want to force him to take
yeah the rook is misplaced i agree
now we gotta get the queen in okay
so how are we going to do that here
no i mean a7 he can play night shake and
take back
you can start
check if it takes
yeah it doesn't make he has to take it
doesn't have no choice now
or you can go here
now check he has to take anyway
and then you want to win the rook
because if he consolidates
he will probably fight but now he goes
here and now
and if he goes there now what's the
winning move
yeah absolutely
and now you're threatening to take this
guy and you're threatening to take the
rook
and the game is over okay so this is the
game
of avarbach against aronin
from 1963 ussr
moscow championship so once again guys
uh this was just a very nice technique
at the end okay
but most important thing here is you you
have a target you want to sacrifice only
six
okay but you have to do it that way so
you can break through
okay you have to do it always so you can
break through that's why you want to try
to play the move
bishop c6 okay because bishop c6 will
make him move
will make the bishop move because if he
does anything else you just take
so he has to take aronin yeah 1963.
there was a grandmaster named
very strong player now we take
take take and not this way if you don't
this way you're allowing to defend like
this
okay you don't want that you want to go
this way
because now you're attacking the bishop
and you're attacking on f8
and that's why he cannot do anything
now pressure on c6 and there is a
pressure now as well
on there's a pressure now as well on uh
f8 so he cannot do anything guys and uh
so his best option is this but this is a
pretty
pretty loss because basically you've
blocked
maybe another pawn on b7 or something
maybe you'd have but you know you have
three pawns basically
three pawns is going to be quite a lot
so he's not going to be able to defend
this position okay
slowly but surely as you can see with b3
can be two
white improves the position and goes for
a win
all right thank you everybody for
watching this two lectures
and i will be back on sunday for some
more classes
and next week as well so looking forward
seeing you all soon and again thank you
very much everybody
for watching okay thank you guys
have a good evening
you